everyone wants to be rich everyone wants  to have a six-pack your goals don't make  you unique it's the activities that you  do that make you unique the goal of the  winner is to commit to the activities  the goal of the loser is to commit to  the goal 52 of 18 year olds High School  seniors think they're going to be  millionaires by 25. the world is going  to be shook many of you will fail and  that's because most of you have the same  goal 52 you think you're gonna be a  minor right it's just math but only a  small percentage will because if you  want to be a millionaire you're not  going to focus on making a million  dollars you're going to focus on the  stuff that makes a million dollars